- Just close your eyes until you're 29.
Just close your eyes until you're 29.
♫ We're unstoppable
As you guys can see, it
was super passionate,
I'll say it again.
Monday morning is super
gloomy in New York.
Really trying to figure
out how to show you guys
these meetings, so this is how I want you
to start the blog, Tyler, period.
You can take care of the
rest, you know I never impose.
But desperate to figure
out how to hack in here,
so let me try to figure this out.
So first meeting was with Steve Babcock,
the chief creative officer
and Claude, the head of HR,
and we're just auditing the
200 people in the department
who's killing it, I think
it's imperative to dig deep,
and spend time with your big players,
so I want to do more of that going
into the rest of my career,
and then talking about
who is struggling and making
sure we're giving them
radical candor, I think you
never want to be in a place
where you surprise people
if they're struggling,
and I think at times
when you're good peeps,
you kinda want to hold it in
and I think we do that in our real lives,
and I think we do it in organizations
and so that's very much top
of mind, and so I did that.
I then jumped into a
meeting here with Alan,
Alan is the CFO, and I'm
just getting the updates
to how August went, what went
well, what didn't go well.
And plenty did not go
well, plenty of stresses.
This tone that you're feeling
from me comes from that,
as I'm processing like
how do I get better?
Then, fun things happen, like
Andy K. gets a new haircut,
and it puts me in a good mood.
Show me those sides, show
me that fading, Andy, yeah!
And so for all the headaches,
you get some awesome news
like Andy's new haircut
it makes you feel like
you're heading to Amsterdam.
I don't know what D-rock is doing,
this guy just sitting
there thinks he's fancy.
So this is how the place
is run these days I guess.
Plenty of work to do.
Hey everybody this is Gary Vanderchuck,
super pumped about my trip to Singapore,
big shoutout to Slush, very
excited about doing this Q&A,
let's get into it, D-rock.
You know, I think my biggest mistakes
have been the things I haven't done,
invest early in Uber,
pass on TV shows that became monster hits,
you know, I'm just
crippled by opportunity.
So my mistakes are not I did this, I lost,
I came back up, they're hidden mistakes,
which in a lot of ways are even worse,
because you're always wondering
what if, what if, what if?
Or mental strains, you
know, you want to win,
and you're always questioning
I mean should I have
started to enter Media?
Should I have gotten into
my family's business?
Would I have gone to Silicon Valley
in 1996 and made a
quadrillion, I don't know.
You know, it all is what
it is, I can't complain.
I don't dwell, I hate these questions,
to be very frank with you,
because you're asking me
to look back and I think
that's a fundamental flaw.
It just doesn't matter what
my biggest mistakes are,
it just matters what I do with
those things going forward
and so that's where I'm at.
- So this is a review,
firstly, for crushing it.
- Go ahead.
So hey youtube, this is
Colin, a very handsome
and very smart, Colin helps-
he's basically my copywriter,
ghostwriter of my current stuff,
Steph writes the books,
but for these articles
you've been seeing for
Medium and GaryVaynerchuk.com
this was a whole new thing we're doing
called crushing it, which is more
him interviewing people that
are following the thing,
Crushing it, the book
coming out in January,
but my blog posts, he
takes content from the web,
starts the framework,
pitches me the concepts
of like articles we should be writing,
based on what he's seeing in the cycles,
I say yes or no, transcribes
my words into english,
asks me five to seven
questions to add more to it,
then reads it back, then I
change an adjective or two here,
and make sure it's my voice,
but that's how I scale
with the infrastructure.
- Because I heard him say 90% of people
won't do this, so what got you started?
- They key reason that people win
in the 2017 flip challenge-
Like what is this hammer worth?
More than anything, is the
upfront work and research.
Babbin didn't hear that
I have creators now,
and wants to learn while they're here,
he was a creator, as a 12, 13-
when did you start, did you start making?
Nine.
The upfront works.
So anybody who's trying to
do the 2017 flip challenge
$7.99 better than zero!
Go and study all the sold results
of stuff that you see, so
that you become educated,
and then we can go find it; go ahead.
Guys everybody, listen.
You don't have to be that wealthy-
like Americans, especially Americans,
you have shit around your house.
Literally clothes you don't wear anymore
that can start that capital.
This is a great story, keep going.
- Should he quit his
job working at the mall?
- Anybody that works at the mall
should quit right now and
do the 2017 flip challenge.
Now, when I say quit
right now, quit mentally,
do what this dude did,
and get some sort of base
over the next month,
and get the fuck out of there by December.
I've just become completely
and utterly obsessed
with the destruction of-
I basically think what's
happening in the creed
of production world is what
happened with Uber and Amazon.
What do I want to do?
I want to let the market come to me.
Just talking about Vayner Productions,
our production facility
out in Long Island city,
operations, make it
better, make it better.
What are we doing, how are
we servicing ourselves?
How are we going to
service the outside market?
provide original content?
Like fucking just running an organiz-
this is just a meat and potatoes
kind of episode, I hope.
Run my business, Vayner X.
♫ I got this soft setting on comfortable
♫ Netting a G on my mind
♫ I been at this seven years
♫ And watched family fall behind
♫ I'm losing touch with my people
♫ I'm throwing dough in the back
- You know, if we didn't
think we were capable
of building one of the biggest firms,
built on, I think everybody
talks the same game,
so to me it's just gonna
be about execution.
I just got off the phone call
with some Vayner Sports
business, still working on that,
and now jumping on a call with actually
the former contestants
from Plan of the Apps.
I'm not a one and done guy,
I'm in the business of people forever
looking at Bavin right
now, who I love so much,
who's now in my heart and family.
Do I want him to be with me forever?
Yes.
Do I see a scenario where tomorrow
or seven years from now he may
want to go do something else?
Sure.
But does that mean that's
it's like done and sealed?
Absolutely not.
Always in the family.
Obviously the people that
are there, you gotta treat
a little bit better,
otherwise they'll leave,
but that's that.
Same way I think about junior sports.
If a kid signs with us
and blows out his knee,
he's in the Gary Vayner Sports business.
He comes and works for
Vayner, I get him a job,
I get him or her a job,
that's what I'm about.
And that's what I'm doing
with those contestants.
So I like that.
You need to be optimistic and patient,
and everything will work out.
If you're not, it won't, the end.
You're fucking 21.
Like I get that you want to apply it,
like I want to apply it too,
lack of patience, bro.
Wrap your head around not giving a fuck
about any advancement until you're 29,
but then every day trying to get better,
you will fucking win.
Just close your eyes until you're 29.
Patience, man, patience.
Everybody's looking up to audit themselves
where they are now.
I promise you, show me everybody
you think is fancy at 22.
Show me where they were.
Fucking laying in their
vomit in their dorm room.
You know what I mean?
Like cool, like I get it.
Just don't vomit in your
dorm room and work every day,
but don't look at yourself at
21, do you know what I mean?
Just close your eyes until you're 29.
All your buddies for the next ten years
are going to be judging themselves,
they're gonna be looking
around, like where am I?
Where am I?
Every body who is trying to
figure out where they are
you need to be thoughtful,
but people are dwelling.
There's a big difference
between awareness and dwelling.
Be aware of where you're at,
I'm always aware of where
I'm at, but I don't dwell.
I don't obsess over.
And people that dwell and
obsess over where they're at
in their 20's, you just
close your eyes.
(hip hop music)
Alright, a pretty shitty travel experience
flight had some issues,
couldn't find our driver,
got a cab, wasted a shitload of time.
Jordan hates wasting time, I hate it more.
Work out next.
(hip hop)
Going to Amsterdam right
now, looking forward to it.
I'm having a huge problem with my TSA.
Tyler Z., I'm not happy.
I'm not fancy, it's just
those minutes count, so ...